hablemos un poco de una palabra que
puede hayas escuchado antes
la palabra guión
hablemos de lo que es y luego hablemos
de tendencias en la tabla periódica de
lo difícil que es hacer algo un guión y
en particular qué tan difícil es hacer
algo un guión positivo un guión es sólo
un átomo o una molécula que tiene carga
y tendrá carga si los protones no son
iguales a los electrones los neutrones
también constituyen a los átomos pero
los neutrones son neutrales de donde
obtendrás la carga será de los protones
y de los electrones tendrás una carga
número d
pero
en tu átomo o molécula la molécula es
solo un conjunto de átomos unidos si el
número de protones no es igual al número
y puedes tener iones positivos si el
número de protones es mayor al número de
electrones los protones son positivos y
los electrones son negativos y puedes
tener iones negativos si el número de
electrones es mayor al número de
protones por ejemplo si sólo tienes al
hidrógeno en su estado neutro tiene un
protón y un electrón pero si quitas al
electrón entonces el hidrógeno tendrá
una carga positiva y en esencia solo
sería su isótopo más común solo sería un
protón por sí mismo y entonces cuando
hablamos de un guión positivo como este
donde nuestros protones son más que los
electrones el número de protones es
mayor que el número de electrones
llamamos a estos
ocasión es otra manera de llamar a un
guión positivo
de la misma manera puedes tener iones
negativos como por ejemplo el flúor
el flúor gana un electrón tendrá una
carga negativa tendrá una carga de -1 y
llamamos a
y un negativo
y hoy
y la manera en la cual recuerdo esto es
que la a significa lo opuesto o la
negación de algo y ya que este es un
guión negativo de alguna manera podrías
pensar que estamos negando al guión ya
expuesto esto pensemos en qué tan
difícil sería ionizar diferentes
elementos en la tabla periódica y en
particular piensa en qué tan difícil
sería transformarlos en cationes y para
pensar en eso presentaremos un concepto
llamado energía de ionización energía
d
llegó
saa
y esta se define como la
y a
requerida
no hay querida
pero
y podrías haberla llamado energía de
capio nización porque realmente es la
energía requerida para remover un
electrón y hacer al átomo más positivo
así que pensemos en las tendencias y ya
tenemos un poco de bases de los grupos
en la tabla periódica por ejemplo si nos
enfocamos en especialmente si nos
enfocamos en el grupo 1 y ya hemos
hablado del hidrógeno que es el caso
especial en el grupo 1 pero si vemos
todo lo que está abajo del hidrógeno si
vemos a los metales alcalinos aquí
ya hemos hablado del hecho de que estos
están muy dispuestos a perder un
electrón porque porque si pierden un
electrón llegan a la configuración
electrónica de gas noble antes que ellos
dentro de la tabla periódica si el litio
pierde un electrón entonces tiene la
configuración en el último orbital como
el él tiene dos electrones en su último
orbital y típicamente hablamos de la
regla del octeto pero si vemos elementos
como el litio o el helio son felices con
dos así que solo pones dos electrones en
ese primer orbital pero el resto de los
elementos el sodio el potasio etcétera
etcétera si tomas un electrón de ellos
tendrá la configuración electrónica del
gas noble que está antes que ellos en la
tabla periódica y del sodio para abajo
el último orbital tendrá ese 8 perfecto
a litio si le quitas un electrón tendrás
al él tendrás dos electrones en su
último orbital podrías imaginar que la
energía de ionización de aquí la energía
requerida para quitar electrones de tus
metales alcalinos es muy baja y déjame
escribir eso y cuando digo baja estoy
hablando de energía de ionización baja
qué pasa mientras me muevo a la derecha
de la tabla periódica vayamos hasta el
otro extremo de la tabla periódica si
voy aquí a los gases nobles los gases
nobles ya hemos mencionado que son muy
muy estables no quieren que se metan con
sus configuraciones electrónicas sería
muy difícil del neón para abajo tienen
sus 8 electrones cumplen con la regla
del octeto el helio tiene 2 y esto llena
el primer orbital es muy difícil quitar
un electrón de aquí por lo que tiene una
elevada energía de ionización baja
energía es fácil quitar electrones
especialmente el primer electrón y aquí
tienes una energía de ionización alta
aquí es
la energía de ionización alta y esa es
la tendencia general a través de la
tabla periódica mientras vas de
izquierda a derecha
más de energía de ionización baja a
energía de ionización alta y qué pasa
con las tendencias en dirección vertical
en la tabla periódica entre cada grupo
si ves a los metales alcalinos de aquí
si estamos justo hasta abajo si estamos
viendo el cesio aquí es electrón en el 1
2 3 4 5 6 en el sexto orbital que se
estará más alejado que el único electrón
que tiene el litio en su segundo orbital
por lo que estará más lejos podría decir
que no estará tan estrechamente enlazado
al núcleo ese electrón será mucho más
sencillo de quitar que el electrón en el
último orbital del litio por lo que la
energía de ionización
es más baja más
y eso también será verdad para los gases
nobles aquí
el xenón sus electrones en el orbital
más alejado aunque tenga 8 electrones de
valencia están más alejados del núcleo
por lo que la energía requerida para
moverlos será alta pero será más baja
que la energía de digamos el neón o el l
baja
nuevamente la energía de ionización va
de baja a alta si te mueves de izquierda
a derecha y de baja a alta si vas de
abajo hacia arriba
o podemos decir como tendencia general
que si vas de abajo en la izquierda
arriba a la derecha vamos de baja
energía de ionización es muy fácil
remover electrones de estos elementos de
aquí a energía de ionización alta es muy
difícil remover electrones de estos
elementos de aquí y puedes ver esta
tendencia en mediciones de energía de
ionización y me gusta ver gráficas como
estas porque es como si te mostrara de
dónde viene la tabla periódica
cuando la gente notó este tipo de
tendencias periódicas debió decir bien
hay ciertos patrones comunes aquí pero
en esta en particular vemos en
efe
tenemos energía de ionización en
electrón volts que de hecho son unidades
de energía los puedes convertir a jules
si quieres y luego por aquí estamos
incrementando el número atómico
empezamos con el hidrógeno luego vamos
con el helio luego vamos del hidrógeno y
helio al litio y déjame mostrarte lo que
está pasando aquí
hidrógeno
el yo el el yo aquí es muy estable por
lo que es muy difícil remover electrones
y luego vas al litio con el litio como
dijimos antes es un metal alcalino
mueves un electrón y llega a un estado
estable se necesita muy poca energía
para remover ese electrón y luego
mientras vamos de izquierda a derecha de
la tabla periódica si vas de los metales
alcalinos a los gases nobles vemos que
la energía de ionización se incrementa y
hay pequeñas caídas aquí
y podrías pensar porque estas caídas
ocurren cuando ves la tendencia general
de los metales alcalinos a los gases
nobles de los metales alcalinos a los
gases nobles
de metales alcalinos a gases nobles y
algo que podrías estar diciendo es mira
de aquí a acá es la misma distancia que
de aquí a acá y luego tenemos una
distancia más grande aquí
qué es lo que pasa aquí tenemos que
recordar que ahora tenemos todos
nuestros elementos del bloque de ya que
llegamos a aquí estamos sumando todos
los elementos del bloque de en el cuarto
periodo tenemos a esos elementos
añadidos aquí elementos del bloque d
elementos del bloque de y aquí tiene
elementos de los bloques d
y entonces ves la tendencia general que
tus metales alcalinos tienen una energía
de ionización muy baja tus gases nobles
tienen una energía de ionización muy
alta pero mientras los átomos aumentan
su tamaño la energía de ionización baja
y baja un elemento como el radón el cual
sabemos es un gas noble su energía de
ionización debido a que sus electrones
están mucho más alejados del núcleo o
están bastante alejados del núcleo su
energía de ionización
de hecho menor que la del hidrógeno
espero hayas encontrado eso interesante